how many times have you started learning
a language from scratch
only to give up in a matter of weeks or
months
once you lost steam you're probably
trying to find a quick fix but
it did not work hey guys we'll get to
the video in a moment but before we do
i just want to let you know that i'll be
making a very special announcement at
the end of this video
if you're interested in learning about
how i can help you take your language
learning to the very next level
then stay tuned till the very end thanks
have you ever asked yourself why it
didn't work
hi my name is luca lampariello and today
i'm going to answer
two burning questions that all language
learners
ask themselves first why is it so damn
hard
to learn a new language and second how
can i make it more pleasant
the reality is that if you make it
through the first three
to six months with a solid routine that
you enjoy
the thought of giving up will not even
cross your mind anymore
to help learners get through this tough
time i've developed a method that aims
to build a solid core
in any language in three to six months i
call this method
by direction translation and it's what
i've used to learn
11 of the 14 languages i've learned so
far
i get it i get it a bit of skepticism is
healthy but if you think that a person
who speaks a second language is a genius
or has a knack for languages
you are indirectly telling yourself you
do not have one
if you think he has an extraordinary
memory or must have lived abroad for
years you're creating
excuses for yourself in other words you
tend to ascribe your incapacity to learn
a language to genetics
while language learning comes down to
will writ
discipline and yes brain friendly
methods
let me tell you again all this stuff of
i'm not good at languages is just in
your head
anyone can learn any foreign language
now i'm telling you all this because
not only this is a tried and tested
method through which i've learned 14
languages but i've also used it to coach
hundreds of language learners over the
past 10 years
hundreds of people from all walks of
life who exactly like you did not even
know the potential they had
to learn languages and beyond ok
assuming that you might still not be
convinced but
are intrigued by the whole thing what's
next i know that no two people learn a
language in the same way so you might be
asking yourself
why did this method work for so many
people the answer is simple
this method is built on a set of
fundamental learning principles that can
be adapted to the circumstances of any
language learner
in fact i've spent 10 years refining and
perfecting this method so that it's
flexible enough
to suit anyone's unique learning needs
and that's what makes it so effective by
direction translation does not force you
into blindly and rigidly adopting
someone else's learning study regimen
instead it gives you the freedom to
adjust
and tweak the method according to your
needs preferences
and energy level so what is this
bi-directional translation method
as the name suggests bi-directional
translation or a bdt
is a method that focuses on translation
but
not in a traditional way with the bdt
you build your language skills by
analyzing
translating and re-translating
interesting language texts in powerful
brain-friendly ways this is a focused
and effort-driven process which enables
you to assimilate
new information at a rapid pace but the
best part is that
you do not need to drill additional
grammar and vocabulary exercises to
learn
and progress this method is designed to
help you internalize grammar structures
in a natural way
without needing to dig through boring
grammar texts
and mind numbing verb tables as polyglot
catalog used to say
you learn grammar from language and not
language from grammar
that's how you will do things with a bdt
in other words the bi-directional
translation method is designed to help
you learn the language holistically
without neglecting any of the four core
areas of language learning i've been
coaching language learners for 10 years
both one-on-one and in small groups and
although i love my job the feedback i
get on this channel made me realize
one very important thing well many
people want
and need someone to help them reach
their language learning goals
few of them can afford the personalized
services of a language coach
that's why my team and i decided to
condense
all of my knowledge and coaching
experience into a comprehensible course
that any language learner can benefit
from
this course will teach you the five
golden principles of successful language
learning and take you through my
bi-directional translation method step
by step so that you can apply it to any
and
every language you want to learn though
you'll be learning my method
what i'll really be teaching you is the
single set of principles that
form the foundation of any language
learning success
once you internalize these principles
they can be applied
time and time again to any language and
any circumstances
i'll even teach you to apply them to the
bdt itself creating a unique
personalized method that grows and
evolves as you do
the course itself is divided into 12
modules that you can follow at your own
pace
so that you won't ever feel overwhelmed
the first part of the course addresses
the main
principles that all successful language
learners abide by
through principle number one learn every
day you will learn
why frequency is more important than
intensity and you'll understand how to
build a discipline to make language
learning happen
every day through principle number two
learn holistically you will see how
language
is a skill that is made up of
interconnected sub-skills
reading writing speaking listening etc
and that developing these sub-skills in
unison will greatly improve
your language abilities overall for
principle number three interleave your
activities you will see how regularly
rotating your learning activities can
help your sub-skills grow at a faster
rate
through principle number four space out
your learning you will learn how timing
when
and how you review previously learned
material will help you remember
everything better and for longer
through principle number five value
skills over factual knowledge you will
understand the difference between
learning skills and learning facts
and how skill development requires a
specialized learning approach
separate from the one you likely used in
most in-person language classes
once you've set the stage through
learning these principles
the second part of the course dives into
exactly what the bi-directionalization
method is
and how you can use it to learn any
language from the very beginning
you will learn to use the intensive
analysis technique to analyze
and deeply understand any bilingual text
in your target language
apply the phonetic analysis technique to
understand the sounds
and intonation of your target language
all with
a few strokes of a pencil review
previously learned material in a way
that is fun
dynamic and memorable use your native
tongue as an indispensable translation
tool for quickly understanding the
structural components
of any new language translate from your
native tongue
back into your target language in a way
that shows the progress
you've made and provides invaluable
feedback on the quality of your learning
efforts
so far the course itself comes complete
with
dozens of instructional videos and
screencasts and on top of
that you'll get tons of supplementary
pdfs and audio files that can help
guide you through various aspects of the
method if you follow the principles in
this course and its modules
without a doubt you will be successful
in setting a foundation in your target
language that can never be shaken
you will have built a deep lasting
motivation that you'll fuel your desire
to stick to your target language
every single day no matter how busy how
tired or how frustrated
you might be two important final notes
as i already mentioned this course
will teach you the ins and outs of my
bi-directional translation method
i've tested this method hundreds of
times in both my own language learning
and through teaching it to dozens of
coaching clients
so i'm quite certain it can be used to
learn or improve any language
regardless of your level that being said
i've built this course to help you learn
and use the bi-directional translation
in the situation it is best suited for
starting to learn
a foreign language for the very first
time with that in mind this course is
for you
if you're an absolute beginner that is
you have no experience in your target
language
you are a false beginner that is you
have some prior experience in your
target language but you gave up for
any reason you're looking for a new out
of the box learning method that you can
apply to any foreign language you might
learn in the future
you are a curious person and want to
explore new ways of learning that are
backed by years research and
experimentation
this course is not for you if you're
currently
at an intermediate or advanced level in
your target language
you're looking for a course that
directly teaches speaking skills in your
target language
you're an expert language learner with
your own preferred methods of language
learning
you're looking for a method that will
solve all of your language learning
problems without you having to invest
any time effort or energy one last
observation
the experience of most online courses is
a solitary one
you go through the modules do as much or
as little of the work as you like and
have
few interactions if any with the course
instructors
or other learners this is not so with
become a master language learner the by
direct controllation
this course was built with community in
mind so you'll have ample opportunities
to interact with me
my expert team and the other learners
who are taking the course
alongside you you will be able to ask
questions post comments
chat with me and my team and even work
with us live
in the form of regular community
webinars
as the old african proverb goes if you
want to go quickly
go alone if you want to go far go
together
we've put together this course and this
community so all of us
can go far together in this exciting
life-changing journey of learning a
language
if you're interested in learning about
the course click the link in the
description box which will take you to a
page
with any and all information you will
need about the course
i truly hope to see you there and as
always
thanks for watching and happy language
[Music]
learning
you